[Applaus]
meine Damen und
Herren zunächst möchte ich im eigenen
Namen aber auch im Namen der CDU CSU
Bundestagsfraktion dem heute morgen
vereidigten neuen polnischen
Ministerpräsidenten auch unsere
herzlichen
Glückwünsche übermitteln und der neuen
Regierung in Polen alles erdenklich Gute
wünschen für Polen aber auch für uns
gemeinsam in Europa das ist ein guter
Beginn des heutigen Tages
gewesen dieses gute Miteinander in
Europa hängt von
handlungsfähigen Regierungen ab es hängt
insbesondere von einer
handlungsfähigen Bundesregierung ab denn
Deutschland ist nun einmal das geostrat
wichtigste Land in Europa ob wir es
wollen oder nicht und deswegen war es
keine Überraschung Herr Bundeskanzler
dass sie auf Biegen und Brechen versucht
haben heute morgen durch die Nacht durch
und es war nicht die erste einen
Kompromiss zu finden in dem anhaltenden
Haushaltsstreit ihrer Regierung und das
was sie hier als ein
geordnetes Verfahren dargestellt haben
ist in Wahrheit und so hat es ja auch
ihr Parteivorsitzender richtig gesagt
eine handfeste Regierungskrise gewesen
die sie heute morgen allenfalls mit
einem Formelkompromiss abgeschlossen
haben es ist sicher für eine
abschließende Bewertung dessen was sie
nur in einer Bundespressekonferenz oder
einen Pressestatement mehr war ja nicht
gesagt haben viel zu früh aber eines ist
doch jetzt schon deutlich erkennbar sie
versuchen fortzusetzen was sie seit dem
Beginn ihrer Regierung tun nämlich
eine Quadratur des Kreises indem sie
dieser Fraktion alle Ausgaben für die
Sozialpolitik weiter ermöglichen dieser
Fraktion alle Möglichkeiten ja ich komme
darauf zu sprechen alle
Möglichkeiten weiter fr Esen dass ich
jetzt gerade mit den vor mit den
Zwischenrufen schon wieder Anfang nehme
ich die Gelegenheit einfach mal wahr
ihnen zu sagen
[Musik]
sie haben auf ihrem auf ihrem
Bundesparteitag der SPD in der letzten
Woche es für richtig
gehalten zu
sagen CDU und CSU hetzen im Chor mit der
AFD gegen die
Ampel und wenn das dann noch der Beifall
hier in dieser Fraktion ist der das
auslöst wenn ich sie
zitieressen ziemlich genau auf was wir
uns einzustellen haben in der
Auseinandersetzung mit ihrer Partei und
ihrer Fraktion sie unterschreiten sie
unterschreiten hier jedes zulässige Maß
an persönlicher Herabsetzung ich weise
das hier mit größter Entschiedenheit
zurück was sie da auf diesem Parteitag
gemacht haben ich wei es mit größter
Entschiedenheit zurück es gibt niemanden
der sich überbieten läs in der
Abgrenzung zu dieser Fraktion da wie wir
und Sie wissen das kriegen die
entsprechenden Kommentare in der
Öffentlichkeit dafür was sie hier
gemacht haben es ist ein Tiefpunkt in
der politischen Kultur dieses Hauses
wenn es dazu auch noch Beifall aus ihrer
Fraktion gibt wenn ich sie zitiere mit
dem was sie da auf ihrem Parteitag
gesagt haben es ist eine
Unverschämtheit ich komme
zurück ich komme zurück auf die
europäische Politik und auf den Haushalt
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland meine
Damen und Herren für eine Bewertung ist
es heute zu früh sie versuchen es ja
fortzusetzen was sie in den letzten zwei
Jahren gemacht haben indem sie dann auch
der FDP jetzt jedenfalls vordergründig
einräumen dass sie eine Abweichung von
der Schuldenbremse jedenfalls heute
nicht mehr vorschlagen wollen aber
Bundeskanzler das was sie hier zur
ukreine gesagt haben ist doch bereits
die Ankündigung dass sie es in den
nächsten Monaten tun werden und der
Trick ist doch durchschauar sie geben
jetzt das Geld aus dass sie im Klima und
transformationsfond haben sie geben das
Geld aus was sie für die gesamten
Transferleistungen in den Arbeitsmarkt
aufwenden wollen und dann werden Sie uns
zur Mitte des Jahres sagen tja das ist
nun alles unvorhergesehen gewesen was da
in der Ukraine auf uns zukommt und jetzt
müssen wir noch einmal die
Haushaltsbeschlüsse überprüfen Herr
Bundeskanzler das
Grundgesetz das Grundgesetz sieht
eine das Grundgesetz sieht eine
unvorhergesehene Notlage vor für die
über schreitung der Kreditgrenzen der
Schuldenbremse sie wissen dass sie das
nicht einhalten können was sie heute
morgen hier gesagt haben es ist eine
vorhersehbare Notlage die sie spätestens
zur Mitte des Jahres erklären werden
müssen und dann wollen sie uns in
Anspruch nehmen noch einmal für die
Überschreitung der Verschuldungsgrenze
des Grundgesetzes diesen Trick lassen
wir Ihnen nicht durchgehen Herr
Bundeskanzler es ist die übliche es ist
die übliche trierei
eines Bundeskanzlers der dieses Merkmal
seiner Politik mitgenommen hat aus dem
Bundesfinanzministerium und heute
unverändert fortsetzt mit dem was sie
eben in ihrem pressenstatement und
später hier in der Regierungserklärung
zum Ausdruck gebracht haben es ist
finanzpolitische trixserei mehr ist es
nicht imassich den
No Lage in der Ukraine ist so wie sie
sie beschrieben haben sie ist vielleicht
sogar noch ein bisschen schwieriger die
politische die politische Stabilität
dieses Landes nimmt ab die militärische
Gefährdung dieses Landes nimmt zu weil
sie natürlich genauso wissen wie wir
alle dass Russland in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten seine Rüstungsanstrengungen
vervielfacht hat dass dort mittlerweile
Munition und militärisches Gerät im
großen Umfang nicht nur eingesetzt
sondern vorrätig gehalten wird für die
nächsten großen offensiven und sie
wissen dass unter den gegebenen
Umständen dieses Land überhaupt keine
Chance hat diesen Krieg zu gewinnen sie
wissen es dass es so ist und wenn es
heute so ist fast zi Jahre nach dem
Beginn dieses Krieges dann hat diese
Lage dort auch etwas mit ihrer
Zögerlichkeit der Zögerlichkeit der
Bundesregierung zu tun auch mit ihrer
anhaltenden unbegründeten
Zögerlichkeit diesem Land auch
militärisches Gerät zur Verfügung zu
stellen dass das Land seit Monaten
dringend braucht und ich kann nur das
wiederholen was ein Kollege aus unserer
Fraktion in den letzten Tagen gesagt hat
sie täuschen die Öffentlichkeit
unverändert darüber warum sie eigentlich
Taurus marschfuörper nicht liefern sie
behaupten das dürften wir angeblich aus
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland nicht und
bleiben jeden Beweis dafür schuldig
welche Begrenzung es da eigentlich in
ihrer Regierung für diese Entscheidung
er gibt
sie haben Herr Bundeskanzler relativ
kurz nur und ich kann verstehen warum
über ein weiteres Thema gesprochen das
auf dem Europäischen Rat eine Rolle
spielen wird nämlich die gemeinsame
europäische Asylpolitik das hat ja
Gründe dass sie darüber so kurz hier
gesprochen haben denn eine Stunde bevor
sie eben ihr Pressestatement abgegeben
haben kam die Nachricht dass in ihrer
Koalition die Bemühungen um die
Verabschiedung des asylpaketes in diesem
Jahr gescheitert sind Herr Bundeskanzler
das waren Vorschläge die haben sie noch
im November nach der letzten
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz als
historisch bezeichnet da haben sie hier
gestanden und gesagt wir haben uns mit
den Ministerpräsidenten und zwar allen
16 darunter auch ein grüner
Ministerpräsident mit Frau Laub Frau
Kollegin geeinigt auf ein umfassendes
asylpaket dass sie noch Ende dieses
Jahres im Bundesrat vorlegen wollen zur
Beschlussfassung das ist heute morgen
krachend gescheitert sie haben ihr
Zusagen gemacht die sie nicht einhalten
können weil sie das Vertrauen in dieser
Koalition zu diesen Fragen einfach nicht
mehr haben sie haben Ankündigungen
gemacht mit einem
rückführungs mit einem
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz sie
haben mir das als ich bei ihnen war am
13 Oktober voller Stolz ausgehändigt sie
haben das selbst gelesen so sagten sie
und das sei eines der handwerklich am
besten gelungenen Werke ihrer Koalition
und waren ganz stolz darauf was sie da
präsentiert haben krachend gescheitert
an dieser Fraktion die das nicht bereit
ist mitzumachen nur damit wir mal über
den Inhalt dieses Gesetzes kurz Klarheit
bekommen da geht es um ganze 600
zusätzliche Rückführungen im Jahr die
diese Koalition nicht bereit ist zu
akzeptieren sie blockieren mit dieser
Koalition die sie hier führen in
Anführungsstriche die Beschlüsse der
Ministerpräsidenten die seit über einem
Jahr mit ihnen darüber Ringen wie wir
denn das Problem der illegalen Migration
nach Deutschland besser lösen können sie
blockieren meine Damen und Herren einen
Vorschlag den Sie selber hier
unterbreitet haben den wir teilen mit
Ihnen dass wir nämlich die Zeit in der
Asylbewerber Leistung gegeben werden von
18 auf 36 Monate verlängern noch nicht
einmal den abschieb gewewahrsam auf 28
Tage zu verlängern sind sie mit ihrer
Koalition in der Lage me Damen und
Herren jetzt hören Sie mal auf hier
herumzuschreien das bestätigt doch nur
was ich zu ihnen gesagt habe se einfach
unappetitlich es ist unerträglich was
sie für Zwischenrufe da aus dieser
Fraktion hier zum Besten
geben Herr Bundeskanzler ich stelle
Ihnen einfach die
Frage nachdem das was da am 6 November
mit ihrer Beteiligung als historisch
bezeichnet worden ist zum Thema
Begrenzung der illegalen Migration nach
Deutschland wie lange wollen Sie sich
eigentlich noch von großen Teilen ihrer
Koalition insbesondere von den Grünen
auf der Nase herumtanzen lassen sie
gefährden doch den letzten Rest ihres
Ansehens ihrer Autorität im Innland wie
im Ausland und glauben Sie doch nicht im
Ernst dass diejenigen die sie da ab
heute Abend in Brüssel treffen glauben
Sie doch nicht im Ernst dass diejenigen
die sie ab heute Abend da in Brüssel
treffen nicht genau wissen was innen
politisch in Deutschland vorgeht und wie
sie hier vorgefüt werden in der
Koalition die sie angeblich führen Herr
Bundeskanzler wenn dies anders werden
soll dann müssen sie ein bisschen mehr
politische Führung übernehmen und ich
fordere Sie auf dass Sie das Paket was
sie mit allen 16 Ministerpräsidenten am
6 November verabschiedet haben dass sie
exakt dieses Paket im Januar des
nächsten Jahres hier im Deutschen
Bundestag als gesetzgebungspaket
vorlegen eins zu eins das was hier
beschlossen worden ist und dass sie
dieses Paket dann mit der
Vertrauensfrage verbinden ob sie
überhaupt noch ob sie überhaupt noch die
Zustimmung ihrer Koalition in diesen
wesentlichen innenpolitischen Fragen
unseres Landes haben Herr Bundeskanzler
wenn sie das nicht machen dann wird das
nächste Jahr genauso chaotisch beginnen
wie das Jahr 2023 zu Ende geht und das
kann sich die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
das können sich die Menschen das können
sich auch die Unternehmen in Deutsch
einfach nicht mehr leisten dieses Land
ist an der Leistungsgrenze angekommen es
liegt in Ihrer Hand das zu ändern und
dazu fordere ich Sie im nächsten Jahr
auf Friedrich März Oppositionsführer
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion sieht
chaotische chaotische Zustände fakt ist
der Ton wirrauer hier im Parlament
Friedrich Merz hat ja kritisiert ich
zitiere die persönliche Herabsetzung
durch Äußerungen beim SPD Parteitag und
den Applaus dafür hier im Plenum zu
Beginn seiner Rede jetzt muss man
allerdings auch dazu sagen bei der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
Ende November zum Haushalt da kam das
hohenelächter in Richtung Bundeskanzler
aus der Unionsfraktion gut ist sicher
beides nicht